[موسيقى]
الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اكد الرئيس
الروسيه على بلاده محاربه ما وصفهم بعملاء
العدو واضاف بوتين في لقاء مع مراسلين
عسكريين مؤيدين للكرملين انه كان بالامكان
الاستعداد بشكل افضل للهجمات على المناطق
الحدوديه الروسيه ولوح انه اذا استمرت
الهجمات فعلى روسيا ان تفكر في ايجاد
منطقه عازله داخل اوكرانيا وقال انه لا
ضروره لاعلان الاحكام العرفيه في روسيا
ولكن لابد وفق قوله من العمل على بعض
المسائل بشكل ادق وقال ان الهجوم
الاوكرانيه المضاد الذي بدا في الرابع من
يونيو الجاري يجري من محاور مختلفه واشار
الى ان خسائر روسيا عشر خسائر الطرف
المهاجم وهدد بوتين باستخدام اسلحه تحتوي
على اليوراني بالمنظم لو استدعت الضروره
ذلك ردا على استخدامها ضد بلاده حسب قوله
لكنه قال بالمقابل ان روسيا مستعده
لمحادثات السلام ان اراد الاخرون لكن ما
يسعون اليه الان هو هزيمه روسيا واكد ان
لدى بلاده خطتها للسلام بشان اوكرانيا ولم
ترفض مطلقا محادثات قد تقود الى تسويه
سلميه واضافت في نفس السياق ان مفتاح الحل
للصرع بين الغرب وسبيل انهائه هو وقف
تزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح